las vegas now host mercedes martinez is
here to cheer us up with some of today's
trending stories
joining us live from the mix 94.1
studios hi mercedes how you holding up
hey doing great you guys have been
cheering me up all morning so thank you
for that but first up
let's talk about harry styles he is
trending this morning
the singer actor and the co-stars of his
new movie don't worry darling
have all been quarantined someone on the
set was exposed to the coronavirus so
filming has been
paused on the movie as of now sources
say the positive test
was not a member of the primary cast but
someone who was
in close enough proximity to them so
sending our well wishes to all of them
also it's hard to believe but
thanksgiving and black friday are right
around the corner
and if you'd like to get a jump start on
your shopping right after you eat that
turkey
it's a no go because a lot of businesses
will be closed on the holiday for the
first time in years
we have stores like target walmart dix
jc penney macy's and best buy
all closing for the holiday now for
walmart
this is the first time they will be
closed in 30 years on thanksgiving
and the decision it was made to give
their employees a break after working
through
this pandemic but remember you can
always shop online
alex i know that you and i are both big
fans of the online shopping
yes you can i can't believe it's almost
thanksgiving it feels way too warm to
even think about eating a bunch of
turkey
i know but it's going to get colder from
what i understand so
you know it'll really feel like it then
i know it
uh well mercedes we all know how much of
a toll this year has really taken on
everyone and now
you can apparently relive this year's
strangest moments
i don't even know if you can put those
into a list
yeah this is a trip down memory lane
that i don't know you if you want to
take it but
there's a new candle out and it's called
the 20 20 candle
it has four different layers and the
makers say
those four layers of scents are staples
of 2020.
so the first the four cents are banana
bread
everyone was making it hand sanitizer
of course woody musks those are supposed
to be like your do
do-it-yourself projects that we all took
on while we're at home
and then budget after shave and earthy
essence now that one is intended to
bring back memories of
joe exotic the tiger king
[Laughter]
remember when we all watch that you can
get it for just under 20
so now i know what i'm getting you for
christmas alex i know you want to
remember that
don't don't put yourself through the
trouble that's uh that's an interesting
group
of sense and then together i can't
imagine how lovely that must smell so
it's just the perfect way to close out
this lovely year
it's it's been a doozy hasn't it i know
it
interesting all right well mercedes
thank you we know we're getting new for
christmas
oh no i'll take anything at this point
have a good weekend thank you enjoy the
radio
all right uh where did we go from there
you guys
this is what this has come to alex the
question so what exactly would you think
that joe exotic would smell like
i don't want to know i don't know
cheap aftershave and sadness yikes and
sadness and some hand sanitizer
apparently